Mark who is barking at the referee as he heads
out for a new stick Jack Hugh swooping in sharp
angle SC haircuts Jack Hughes High stepping
backs off moider below the goal line goalies
close your side door and if you don't the elite
players like Jack Hughes will take advantage of
that daylight shipped ahead for Hughes he's
got Brad with him Hughes to the slot he's SC
Jack Hughes has his second and the double PL
oh my goodness the sublime agility getting
separation in the fadeaway rer across the grave
moved up top slides it right back to Jess for
brat now Jack Hughes takes it down low minute
and 15 left on the power play Luke drives and
scores his first goal this year his
first NHL power play goal devils are
ahead not sure if who was tipped at all
in front but Luke Hughes really got a
lot on this shot from the point rat down
to the doorstep poot sends it right back
to brat poot gets it again Center and
score Jack Hughes a fourth power play
goal this is absolutely beautifully executed
Hughes got his breather he's back on the ice
here he goes he's the NHL's point leader now
with nine he cuts inside and he scores a game
winner and a fourpoint night ends with an
exclamation point Devils winning he steps
on the ice and he makes something happen JT
Miller moves towards the middle Hughes takes
the pass long shot scores as patteron was
right on the doorstep with Hughes rifling
at home to make it one nothing on the power
play Quin Hughes was was vowing to shoot the
puck more and he's done so this season he's
his brother Jack gets it back Jack Hugh shoots
score Hughes threw it on to fley they attempted
home either way the devil's lead and Jack Hughes
is claiming the goal for now his 18th point of the
season one off his SK and off the side of the old
Puck center around Heron over to keep in here's
Heron to all the blues over a minute and a half
as he scores you just felt like eventually the
dam was going to break and Quinn Hughes scores
the opening goal at 759 to make it one nothing
Vancouver as an 18-year-old emergency call up
for the Kings right yes I remember that man here's
Hugh back making four goals in his last two games
against St Louis the blues the only team he has
more go RS against and assists and Quinn Hughes
with his second of the night makes it two nothing
Quinn Hughes back to laery into the middle Philip
heroni still looking for first goal as a KCK
Hughes Moves In The Middle With a wrist shot
scores off the glove of Ken and into the net
and the Canucks have another one Hughes another
point and the Canucks are up three nothing as
Quint Hughes has a goal and two assists take
a pass from Hughes now send one forward here's
kco in Andre kco turning with the Pucket drops
off Hughes in front [Applause] you think it's an
own goal Hughes will get credit the beat goes on
for the con Captain who ties the game in one tied
for the league lead in that category Miller and
it's Quinn Hughes getting lost behind the D and he
wins it Quinn Hughes all along wins it in overtime
second time in his career he's beat the allers in
overtime once in Brooklyn tonight in Vancouver the
kuu rally from two down winning in overtime of
eor shurkin at the moment Hugh retrieves it he
shoots his third shot right here it trickles in
but the whistle had blown so sturing got it but
didn't really catch it clean and after the whistle
that rolled all the way in the pocket entered on
the original shot on a continuous play therefore
we have a goal on the ice so it is a goal players
knowing that if they en on the face off in little
bit they'll be thrown out Hughes with a shot
scores qu Hughes blasted home it's two2 the
captain keeps his streak alive he cuts to the
middle hoglander shoots blocked now he gets it
back to Hughes lots of traffic in front as Quinn
Hughes cuts across the high slot now goes wide on
zerland Hughes shoots he [Applause] scor hon in
and he ties his career high with his eighth of the
Season Canucks open the scoring now watch as he's
got hurdle and then zland they can't stay with him
shuffling bodies for it finally Luke Hughes sweeps
it up Hughes shoots score Luke Hughes puts it in
and the devils are back up five luk Hughes has
had a tremendous game and the move he makes up top
on Alex Tu was at 9899 by the way here's Mercer to
the front h a backhander oh got him that a really
good save there merer across Hughes again he go
Jack Hughes puts it in and the devils are within
one Jack Hughes would not be denied on this ship M
fights off now the Devils break out it's two onone
to fley with Hughes Jack to the front he Rings it
in Devils defend on one end and in a blink they go
the other way Hughes with his eighth of the Year
Jack Hughes with the perfectly placed shot off the
far post conect KN flutters one down sanheim shot
deflected and here come the devil's possible three
onone Jack Hughes accelerates he has Luke to his
right he slides it across and Luke Hugh scores
Hugh squared and the devil's win it oh baby the
Hughes Brothers get it done quickly in overtime
what a pass from Jack and the great speed and
skating ability of his brother Luke ling a pass
across Anthony duclair Halen Addison couldn't call
it in the blue line and Hughes comes away with
it here's Jack Hughes streaking in [Applause]
scor he started the comeback against
the Islanders on Tuesday he BRS the
here watch this shot pinpoint accuracy
up top off the bar look at the shot in
the flex of the stick has it once again
to the point heroni over to Bess moving
up is p he shoots and scores a quick strike
from the Vancouver Canucks as the canu up by
one yeah this huge shot is remarkable I
mean he'll just walk in and from a tough
angle I mean this is perfectly placed and
I need perfectly placed it and what a shot